[Music]
[Music]
the steam coming up it chips I get very
very nostalgic about proper British
ships I mean I love french fries with
all my heart dipped in mayonnaise
plenty of salt but there's just
something really nostalgic about fat
British style ships anything my
great-grandparents ran a chippy so I've
got chip fat in my blood and my nan may
the best chips in the world which was
good because my mum was at the
generation that totally thought chips
were poisoned to children and one day
bless his heart was an insurance
investigator
and he used to come home every day
having seen another chip pan fire likes
nutrients and their intimate chips and
so chips are so emotional for me did you
get your gear ready yeah sunflower oil
which was not easy right mines any
neutral vegetable audible work to three
inches of that we're gonna aim to get
this up to 165 degrees centigrate potato
if you can get it it's Maris Piper I
want chip shop chips it's got to be fat
right it's important that they're
uniform though because you don't want
them kind of cooking it that's exactly
right yeah the original way to do it was
just to chop the chips in the fact that
the outside fries and the inside steams
but it doesn't really work that
brilliantly the second way was to double
cook which is what we're gonna do here
with low temperature first of all which
steams the inside then you heat the oil
back up and you put them back in again
and that crisps the exterior the really
clever way that a lot of chefs are doing
it now it's called triple cooking steam
the potatoes first or boil them then you
dry them then you do the double cook
process I'll never admit this when they
tell you about how they're cooking it
but you probably lose about a third of
your chips because they come out of a
stealing and something just fall apart
you have kindly provided me with this
cooking the monitor yes so this is how
we're going to test the temperature of
the oil what about if you don't have one
of these things if you don't have them a
thermometer or you don't have a deep fat
fryer where you can set the temperatures
then I would suggest you cut the chips
quite thin put them in let them go until
they look good on the outside then pull
one out and try it and that's all you
can really do with that come on honestly
you've got to get these things
every home kitchen in the country it
makes everything so much simpler the
dinner ladies at your kids school use
this bylaw the kid in a paper hat and
Terminal acneic McDowell's uses one of
these by law you can get one online for
12 quid there is no logical reason where
every kitchen has not got one
what's your temperature now don't touch
the bottom of the pan with it ah okay
I did just do that that's okay so I just
cut up one potato two chips about that
size lay them out on a tray on a piece
of kitchen roll mate you are making
pretty heavy weather of cocking some
chips all but got your tongue staying
about making them uniform I'm possibly
overthinking this
I mean after the bread shoot I was quite
prepared to give you a job I'm looking
at it now and thinking you really better
stick to the tape job of making videos
even on the edge just snorted didn't do
to me two batches lower them into the
fats never overfill the pan cuz that's
how you start a chip pan fine just stop
them before they go Brown ruin are you
keeping them failing blonde essentially
kind of parboiling them accepted fats
yes
it's precisely that process they do this
first stage which is called blanching
and you just lay them out on trays like
I hope for underneath them to catch the
grease you have a chip pan going at the
second temperature which is one a five
and how long does their frying it 185
take that three minutes being there go
the team if you have to choose french
fries orb or fat British chips a
question facking the ships every time I
mean I think they both have their place
for me it's about it tasting like
potatoes so the inside of a good chip
should taste like the inside of a proper
baked potato you can get all kinds of
horrible cheap commodity chipping chips
and we throw this yeah you want to do
them that they would do it in a
McDonald's you know you plunge them in
the fat it's all about the fat crisp
outer coat and nobody really cares about
the inside that's fine you could do
cotton wall balls the same way if you're
Monty
but it's kind of fries there's
american-style fries or continental
European style fries with a cold beer
and a pot of mayonnaise and lashings of
salt I mean that is it yes that's a
beautiful thing
don't knock it my bread is buttered and
this is very very important the main
condiment you're thinking about here the
thing that's going to really give a
season your chips beautifully it's going
to be the amount of melted butter that
runs down your chair I think it needs
anything else frankly a chip butty does
it doesn't need any sauce my camera
operator says that I use too much butter
my bread and too much salt on my chips
but I think something like a chip butty
deserves too much of both of those
things okay here we go the steam coming
up it that's good just check camera two
yep
camera two is really happy I'm really
happy are you happy I'm happy
I didn't put any vinegar on I think that
fat ships like this demand it not on the
block to you they're not necessarily I
think when you have the chips in
newspaper which you should by the way
even though it's not illegal anymore
chips up a newspaper tastes different I
think they really need vinegar with them
and what's the song by they're gonna
chip butty you don't need the vinegar as
much because it's about the butter it's
been you talking about the newspaper
because if you're a certain age that's
another thing that just evokes memories
of childhood for me it was a bag of
chips wrapped in the newspaper not open
wrap so you could then unwrap it at home
and eat it
that's what the vinegar would have kind
of evaporated at this point I just asked
for extra batter bits on top you ever do
that scraps oh yes yeah you're starting
to think like a scientific chef you know
imagine how it you you encapsulate those
things and you set them and then you
carry them home and that's a ten-minute
process of steaming and settling of
flavors getting to know each other and
that's got to make it a different
products the one that came out of the
Panama's ate was eaten at the shore
those things are so emotional for us
they're so coded into our brains
emotionally and I think culturally but
I'm not it I just I can't talk about
ships forever
[Laughter]